今日は弾み雪道で今日の動画ですねちょっと真面目な話になるんですけども
まず女かどうかわかんないでそれは皆さんこの動画3時から決めてください今回ですね
あのいつもお世話になっている大家さんに一つ
頼みごとをしようと思いましてこの動画を撮っておりますその他の見事は何かと言い
ますと
ここ今始め子達をメインチャンネルの部屋音外してその命はこの建物にとっているん
ですけども私はじめしたと畑の方でも失礼しておりましてもう前
もう何回も行ってるんですよ一木がめんどくさいと結構頻繁に編集とか撮影の影響で
欠航生き生きしてね本当に大変なんですよ
もう一度抑えしますまず人間でます
こうやって歩いて
ここがいなきゃいけないんだよねー
ってこうやっていかないと一曲ダメなんですよ農牧画面チャンネルから畑に行くって
大変なんすよ i ついます
なんか天井にハシゴとかけをやったんですけどやっぱりめんどくさい
ねぇ
え外でちょっとみんなに関わる話なんですけどあの本当にもったいないっていうかさの
移動時間がゼロにすればそこ
いいとメーサー砲レンズ
ブーバナシア私今から大家さんにドリルで壁に穴を開けて言っ夏知ってるんですこう
やってって取り戻す時もねぇこれで戻ってきて馬鹿って本当にも嫌だなぁあって
でみんなヘラヘラ笑ってますけれども僕はいたって真面目な話をしてまーこのイチゴ
ストにゴースト壁をぶち敗れれば無限の可能性も部屋自体も大きくなりますし移動の
時間もなくなるできる5クール
術でニオイの僕最強だと思ってまして実はただ結構あのー真面目な顔して言ってるん
ですけども外馬鹿げたこと言ってると思うんですよ
賃貸なので壁を壊せということ自体が御法度な
んでまぁ普通に考えちゃいけないですよでもねー上司
僕はこれまでもこれからも2の子たちと思ってませんすでに普通の上の何ができるかを
考えて動いていますのでばんちゃん大家さんだったら
バー
いいよと言ってくれるかも知れませんそれは館内また不動産の関係で大家さんへの誰が
許可を取ってからじゃないと壁をぶち壊せ泣けますよねそれで僕はもう壁をぶち破れ
ないんですよ
すごっボスの皆さん想像してみてくださいこの壁をブチ壊したら未来が広がってるん
ですよ結構ガチですぼくどちらに今からですね親のアポを取っていて今から大家さんに
会いに行っていきます彼の真面目な話をさせ
て頂けますので果たして賃貸の壁は口壊すことができるかどうかをやさん行っていいの
かどうか聞いてみたいと思いますでは
行ってみましょうパイちなみに建物的な話をしましょうこっち裸眼2号スってこちらが
1号室ですこっちがハゲこっちは米とっており
ますで僕どこをどうしたいかと言いますとなあこの隙間にですよその9魔に壁があるん
ですよねそれをドリルで打ち敗れればいいと思っておりますではお家
聞いていきたいとおもいますかっこいいよ
[音楽]
失礼しますどうぞスーツ
はい
最新元気ですかちょっと体重の増加が気になりますあぁそうなんです
私もまたにゅっと長男でみたいですね
そんな話はさておき
今日ちょっと大家さんに
頼みごとがあって
まいりました合法的なことであれば何でもホントですっ
いやとりあえず
可能か
不可能かだけをずっと聞きたく存じておりまして入っ
ズバリ言わせていただきますどうぞ
8ですねー
1号室と濁すの壁をブチ壊すことは可能でしょうか
構造計算上無理だと思いますね
car
me
バッハ
やっぱそうなんですよねそうあそこで支えたアーカムべ
外国馬セラーになっているような
実いいとそれは数年前僕も提案しました
そうなんでさぁ
江蔵上壁が厚いってことですそれすごい中に無理ですカベは無理主取会でちょっとで
こうなんとこうやっちゃいます
上ですか無理です
積車
[拍手]
壁の破壊を大家さんに止められてしまってはじめ絶体絶命のはじめが苦肉の策に選んだ
方法とは
諦めないではじめまだ勝負は終わってないば次回はじめ
無許可で壁をぶち壊すルールスタンバイ